a Massachusetts woman was sentenced to
15 months in jail for using text
messages to encourage her friend to
commit suicide a judge ruled that
Michelle Carter will not have to go to
jail until all of her state appeals are
exhausted she was convicted of
involuntary manslaughter in the death of
Conrad Roy in June 48 hours
correspondent Erin Moriarty spoke with
Roy's family after yesterday's
sentencing hearing it's an interview
you'll see only on CBS this morning
Erin good morning good morning Michele
Carter was allowed to go home last night
with her family after she was sentenced
if her appeals are successful she may
never serve a day behind bars her
punishment left Conrad Roy's loved ones
shell-shocked
and at a loss for words this part of the
case is over it's not for all of us no
it never will be
does this make it any easier though that
you know we want to put it past us we
want to move on the best way we can
Conrad Roy's family was distraught as it
became clear they would not see Michelle
Carter called off to jail there's
nothing she could say that could make up
for what she did no Carter was on the
phone with Roy as he was dying of carbon
monoxide poisoning inside his truck in
July 2014 she never called for help when
Roy apparently changed his mind and got
out of his vehicle she even told him to
get back inside
Roy suffered from depression the hardest
thing for me is to be comfortable in my
own skin and before he killed himself
Carter sent the 18 year old dozens of
texts pressuring him to commit suicide
one read hang yourself jump off a
building stab yourself I don't know
there's a lot of ways Michelle Carter
exploited my son's weaknesses and used
him as a pawn where was her humanity
Carter who herself has struggled with
anxiety and eating disorders wept at
times during the hearing this is a
tragedy for two families judge Lawrence
Moniz sentenced her to two and a half
years in jail but he said Carter would
only have to spend half of that 15
months behind bars she also received
five years probation the judge noted
Carter was three weeks shy of turning 18
at the time of Roy's suicide still a
child in the eyes of the law
the fact that they are still of that
young age off is a greater promise of
rehabilitation judge Moniz then put
Carter's sentence on hold to allow her
lawyers to file Appeals prosecutors were
disappointed they had asked for at least
a seven years sentence and said that
Michelle Carter needs to be held
accountable
Conrad Roy's mother told me last night
that she hopes her son's death will lead
to a new law so that no other mother has
to go through her pain she may be the
most difficult person I've ever had to
talk to you feel she that sentencing did
not you know that word closure did not
help this family it was very very
difficult it's still horrifying to read
these messages every single time you
look at them I can't imagine what it's
like for the family no and you do get
the sense in the court I was surprised
that Michelle Carter didn't actually do
a statement for the judge right and
admitting she recognized what she had
done great work on this and tomorrow
night on 48 hours an in-depth look at
the case the trial and the sentencing 48
hours death by text airs Saturday at
10:00 9:00 central